>> Greg: YOU JUST WANT ME
TO FAIL.
EVERYBODY HERE WANTS ME TO FAIL!
[APPLAUSE]
EVERYBODY -- KEEP CLAPPING.
YOU'RE NOTHING WITHOUT ME.
HAPPY TUESDAY, EVERYONE.
IS IT REALLY HAPPY?
NOT WN IT'S DAY TWO OF...
[SUSPENSION MUSIC]
JOE BIDEN SON OF A BITCH
INSURRECTION.
YES, IT WAS JUST 24 HOURS AGO
THE WORLD WAS ROCKED BY AN
INSIDIOUS FOUL-MOUTHISPLAY OF
INCOHERENT RAGE.
WAS THE SLANDER-IN-CHIEF
LASHING OUT AT OUR VERY OWN
PETER DOOCY SIMPLY GATHERING
INFORMATION FOR OUR BOOK REPORT.
>> POLITICAL LIABILITY AHEAD OF
THE.
[INDISCERNIBLE]
>> WHAT A STUPID SON OF A BITCH.
>> IN CASE YOU MISSED IT, LET'S
DO IT AGAIN IN SLOW-MO.
[SLURRED SPEECH]
THE ORIGINAL S.O.P. FELT OLD
BIDEN STRIKES AGAIN.
OF COURSE, THE TARGET OF HIS
RATH WAS THE ONE REPORTER WHO
ASKED QUESTIONS JOE CAN'T ANSWER
ON AUTO PILOT.
FOX NEWS' PETER DOOCY OR AS WE
LIKE TO SEE OUR VERY OWN.
LIKE WE RAISED HIM IN A PLASTIC
BUBBLE.
WE TOOK A CLIPPING FROM STEVE
DOOCY AND THEN LET MIRACLE GRO
DO THE REST.
DOOCY KNOWN FOR HIS HAIR AND
LENGTHY RAP SHEET WAS NOTICEABLY
SHAKEN UP.
>> SOMEONE CAME UP TO ME IN THE
BRIEFING ROOM A FEW MINUTES
LATER AND SAID, "DID YOU HEAR
WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID?"
AND I SAID, "NO, WHAT?"
HE CALLED YOU A CUPID "S.O.B.?"
I SAID, "DID HE SAY "S.O.B.?"
AND THE PERSON SAID, "NO."
>> Greg: DOOCY JUST TURNED
16 LAST WEEK IS HOME
RECUPERATING SPENDING MOST OF
HIS TIME IN H BEDROOM, PLAYING
VIDEO GAMES AND SMOKING BLUNTS
AND TALKING ABOUT THE HOT N
GIRL IN HOOPOM.
SINCE THE EVENT, -- HOMEROOM,
SINCE THE EVENT, THE SCALLED
PRESIDENT CALLED FOR DOOCY TO
CLEAR THE AIR.
IT INVOLVES OPENING THE WINDOW
THE USE OF AT LEAST 75GLADE
PL-INS.
APPARENTLY IT WAS A PERFECT
PHONE CALL.
ODDS ARE JOE WAS STILL TALKING
10 MINUTES AFTER PETER HUNG UP.
WHAT A PAIR?
A REPORTER WHO NEVER SHAVED AND
A PRESIDENT YOU WOULDN'T LET
NEAR ANYTHING SHARP.
I SAY WHY BOTHER?
THIS IS THE BEST THING PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS EVER DONE SINCE -- IN
FACT, IT'S THE BEST THING JOE
BIDEN HAS EVER DONE!
IT'S DEFINITELY THE MOST HONEST
THING TO COME OUT OF HIS -- COME
OUT OF HIM SINCE HE CROPPED US
AND CAMILLA BOWLES WITH THE AIR
BISCUIT HEAR AROUND THE WORLD.
BETTER THAN EATING CORN POP AND
BREAK DANCING UP THE STARES TO
AIR FORCE ONE COMBINED.
WHEN HE CALLED HIM AN S.O.B.,
WHAT DID HE DO?
HE REMINDED U ON THE GOOD OLD
DAYS, WHERE ALL THERE WAS
PROBLEM WAS VERBAL.
THE ONLY THINGS HURLED THROUGH
THE AIR WERE WORDS AND NOT
MISSILESOINTED AT KIEV.
>> HERE I AM HILLARY CLINTON.
>> THE FAKE PAHONTAS.
>> SLEY JOE BIDEN.
>> LITTLE PENCIL NECK AM
SCHIFF
>> YOU'RE TRYING TO BUILD UP
YOUR ENERGY BUT IT'S NOT
WORKING.
>> WITH JEB'S ATTITUDE, WE'LL
NEVER BE GREAT AGAIN.
THAT I CAN TELL YOU.
>> I LOVE THAT.
YOU CAN GET THE BABY OUT OF
HERE.
>> THIS REALLY STUPID GUY.
>> GET THAT SON OF A BITCH ON
THE FIELD RIGHT NOW -- OFF THE
FIELD RIGHT NOW.
OUT.
HE'SIRED.
FIRED!
>> HONESTLY, I THINK WE SHOULD
LET ME R THE COUNTRY AND YOU
RUN CNN AND IF YOU DID IT WELL,
YOUR RATINGS WOULD BE MUCH
BETTER.
>> Greg: THOSE WERE THE
DAYS.
THE ONLY STRESS WE FELT WERE
FROM TRUMP'S RELENTLESS
BULL-THROATED INSULTS.
IT WAS LIKE WE HAD DON RICKLES
AS PRESIDENT.
HIS RALLIES WEREN'T SO MUCH
RALLIES AS THEY WERE ROESTS.
THE ONLY THING -- ROASTS.
THE ONLY THING MISSING WAS DEAN
MARTIN AND FOSTER BROOKS.
REMIND YOU IT WASN'T JUST A
PROBLEM, IT WAS REALLY THE ONLY
PROBLEM.
BESIDES THAT RASH I GOT IN
TALYM.
THERE WAS NO INFLATION OR HIGH
CRIME UNLESS YOU COUNT ANTIFA OR
BLM NO EDUCATION IMPLOSION OR
ATTACKS ON PARENTS NO DIVIDING
AMERICA INTO US VERSUS THEM
BASED ON VACCINATIONS, RACE OR
PRONOUNCES -- PRONOUNS.
ALL WE HAD WERE MEAN TWEETS AND
HILARIOUS INSULTS.
WHAT WOULD YOU RATHER BE DOING?
PAYING $7 A GALLON FOR GAS OR
LISTEN TO TRUMP CALL BETTE
MIDLER A NAME.
YOU'RE FREE TO GET MAD OR LAUGH
IT OFF, WELL, UNLESS YOU WERE
ROSIE O'DONNELL.
YOU SEE, I WANT MORE OF THAT AND
LESS OF THE OTHER REAL PROBLEMS.
I MEAN, WHAT IF JOE JUST GOT
MORE TRUMPIAN AND LESS -- YOU
KNOW, WELL, BIDENY.
I WONDER WHAT JOE HAS TO SAY?
>> WHAT DO I SAY -- WHAT DO I
SAY -- STUPID SON OF A BITCH!
THAT'S AN EXPRESSION.
IT'S AN EXPRESSION.
I SAY IT ALL THE TE.
I DON'T MEAN ANYTHING BY IT.
I SAID IT TO MY CREAM OF WHEAT
THIS MORNING.
IT BURNED MY TON, STUPID SON OF
A BITCH.
I APOLOGIZE.
I LEANED OVER THE BOWL AND -- I
LIKE TO LET THE STEAM CE UP
AND I SMELL IT.
IT'S VERY NICE.
I SAID, OH MY SWEET FARINA, I'M
SORRY.
I DIDN'T MEAN TO SAY SUCH A
THING.
THAT'S WHAT I CALL HER ON A GOOD
DAY.
MY SWEET FARINA.
ON A BAD DAY, I CALL HER A PUNK
ASS [BLEEP] [BLEEP], PONY
SOLDIER.
>> Greg: IT ILLUSTRATES
WHAT SO MANY PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA
AND ENTERTAINMENT GOT SO WRONG
ABOUT TRUMP, THEIR DERAGMENT
MADE HIM THING HIS WORDS WERE
HIS DEEDS SO THEY TOSS OUT A GUY
WHO DID PRETTY GOOD STUFF BUT
WITH A CAB DRIVER'S MOUTH,
REPLACING HIM WITH A SUPPOSEDLY
GENIAL BUT DECLINING MINDLESS
MESS.
TURNS OUT THE NEW GUY IS AS
GENIAL AS A SCORPION WITH JOCK
ROT.
WHAT I WOULDN'T GIVE FOR THE CAB
DRIVER.
INSTEAD, WE HAVE GRANDPA SIMPSON
DRIVING US OFF A CLIFF.
MEANWHILE, THE SAME IDIOTS W
CASTIGATED TRUMP OR CALLING
JOURNALISTS NAMES ARE EXCUSING
JOE FOR THE VERY SAME THING.
THEY SAY JOE IS TOUGH AND HAS
BACKBONE EVEN THOUG IT'S
CRUMBLING FROM OSTEOPOROSIS.
PUTIN IS SO SCARED, HE MIGHT PUT
A SHIRT ON.
THE PRESS EITHER HAS THE MEMORY
OF A GOLDFISH OR JUST BIAS
A-HOLES.
MY APOLOGIES TOITERAL A-HOLES
IN ONE BRIEF MOMENT, JOE
REMINDED US WHAT WE HAD AND WHAT
WE LOST AND NOW WHAT WE'RE STUCK
WITH.
BUT ALSO THE PRESIDENT SETS THE
TONE, SADLY IT'S CONTAGIOUS.
>> HEY, QUEEN, I JUST WANT TO
LET YOU KNOW ON INSTAGRAM, ALL
YOUR PHOTOS OF PERCI ARE SO
CUTE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> GIVE THAT LITTLE STUPID SON
OF A BITCH A SCRATCH FOR ME, OK?
STUPID SON OF A BITCH.
>> HOW ARE YOU DOING, GUYS?
>> HEY, JESSIE, CONGRATULATIONS
ON THE NEW SHOW, THE RATINGS.
>> THANK YOU, ARE YOU SURPRISED
THEY GAVE IT TO ME?
>> THAT'S A STUPID QUESTION.
OF COURSE I'M SURPRISED.
YOU'RE A BRAIN-DEAD SON OF A
BITCH.
NOT PERSONAL, PAL.
>> HEY, JUDGE, YOU KNOW WHAT?
LET'S NOT.
>> Greg: GOOD CHOICE.
I MENTIONED BEFORE THAT THE
GREAT COMEDIAN JIM SAID HE'D
VOTE FOR JOE BIDEN'S CORPSE OVER
DONALD TRUMP, WHICH IS FUNNY,
BECAUSE HE ALREADY DID.
THE ONLY THING LEFT IS THE
CREMATION IN NOVEMBER AND IT
SERVES AS JUST ONE SELFISH
EXAMPLE OF THOSE WHO CRUSADED
TRUMP OUT OF OFFICE.
THEY WANTED TIR EMOTIONAL
DAMAGE REDUCED EVEN IF IT MEANT
ELECTING SOMEONE WHO WOULD USHER
IN REAL DAMAGE, BE IT DOMESTIC
OR INTERNATIONAL.
SURE, THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO ENDURE
THE TWEETS OR THE BAR.
THAT HELPED THEM GET TO SLEEP IN
THE TRADEOFF, OUR PHYSICAL LIVES
ARE REMARKABLY WORSE, WHETHER
IT'S RAMPANT CRIMINALITY, KIDS
ASKED TO WEAR STUPID MASKS OR A
HOT WAR WITH RUSSIA.
THEY SACRIFICED EVERYTHING TO
GET RID OF THE ORANGE MAN WHO
MADE THEM FEE BAD EVEN THOUGH
HIS GREATEST REAL ESTATE DEAL
WAS LIVING RENT-FREE IN THEIR
HEADS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
T'S WCOME TONHT'S GUESTS,
HE'S MADE MORE LIBERALS CRY THAN
THE FINALE OF "THE WEST WING"
FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY, ARI FLEISHER.
[APPLAUSE]
HE'S LIKE PETER PAN, HE DOESN'T
AGE AND WILL NEVER MARRY A
WOMAN, FOX'S CONTRIBUTOR GUY
BENSON.
SHE'S PROOF THAT IF YOU CAN'T
SAY SOMETHING NICE, YOU CAN GET
A JOB ON TV, FOX'S CONTRIBUTOR
KAT TIMPF AND WHEN HE WEARS A
GREEN SHIRT IN BOSTON, THEY
THINK HE'S FENWAY PARK, MY
MASSIVE SIDEKICK AND THE NWA
WORLDELEVISION AFFILIATE --
YOU'RE A FILTHY, FILTHY LITTLE
MAN, AREN'T YOU?
JUST FILTHY!
I NEED TO GETOU A BATH.
>> YOU STUPID SON OF A BITCH.
THREE THINGS TO SAY ON THIS.
>>reg: SURE.
>> IN MY DEFENSE, NUMBER ONE, IT
WAS A HOT MIC.
I FORGOT I WAS MIC'D UP.
I FORGOT THERE WAS A CAMERA,
EVERY TIME, WIT ALL FOU OF
THEM.
THAT'S NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER TWO, YES, I MAY HAVE
BURST A BIT.
LAST TIME I WAS ON THE SHOW IN
DECEMBER I BELIEVE, WE DID A
WHOLE SEGMENT ON CURSING.
I DECLINED TO CURSE BUT I
PROMISED I WOULD NEXT TIME.
I PAID THAT OFF IN SPADES.
IF I CURSE ANYMORE ON TV, I'D BE
DANA PERINO.
AND FINALLY, I FEEL LIKE WE'VE
HAD OUR DIFFERENCES THROUGH THE
YEARS,UT I HOPE YOU'RE OKITH
HOW THAT SKETCH WENT, BECAUSE I
FEEL LIKE THAT MIGHT BE THE
CLOSEST I'LL EVER GET TO BEING
ON "THE FIVE" AFTER HOW ALL OF
THAT WENT DOWN.
SORRY, EVERYONE, I LOVE Y
DANA, I LOVE YOU, JUDGE
ESPECIALLY.
>> Greg: ISN'T IT A
CONTRAST ON HOW WE HANDLE THINGS
AND HOW CNN DOES?
WHEN TRUMP WOULD GO AFTER THEIR
PEOPLE, THEY'D BE LIKE, OH MY
GOD, IT' THE END OF THE WORLD.
ALL WE DO IS MAKE FUN OF DOOCY.
>> A GUY ON TWITTER SAID IF THAT
HAD BEEN ACOSTA AND TRUMP
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED, ACOSTA
WOULD HAVE SHOWN UP ON CNN IN A
MINUTE IN A NECK BRACE.
"I'VE BEEN HARMED" AND DOOCY
PLAYED IT RFECTLY AND BLEWT
OFF.
>> Greg: DID ANYTHING LIKE
THIS EVER HAPPEN WITH YOUR BOSS,
PRESIDENT BUSH?
I'M TRYING TO REMEMBER HOT MIC
MOMENTS BUT I'M NOT SURE.
>> YES IT DID.
FIRST OF ALL, ACOSTA WOULD HAVE
SHOWN UP IN A NECK BRACE BUT
BEEN REPRESENTED BY MICHAEL --
IT DID, IN THE 2000 CAMPAIGN
WHEN BUSH RAN FOR PRESIDENT, HE
WAS AT A MIC AND HE REFERRED TO
A REPORTER FROM THENEW YORK
TIMES" NAMED ADAM CLIMBER AS A
MAJOR LEAGUE, BEGAN WITH AN A,
TWO LITTLE CURLY LETTERS A
RHYMED WITH TROLL TO WHICH DICK
CHENEY WHEN HE HEARD THAT SAID
"BIG TIME" AND THAT BECAME A
THING.
>> Greg: YES, BUT THE
DIFFERCE WAS -- AND YOU SHOWED
IT WITH THE TRUMP TAPE -- WHERE
BUSH, IT WAS PERSONALITY, WHICH
WAS ALWAYS A GUY THAT COULD
THROW ELBOWS UNDER THE BOARD,
SNAP A TOWEL AT YOU, PEOPLE KNEW
THAT WAS BUSH IN CHARACTER, UM,
BUT JOE BIDEN IS JUST WEIRD.
>> YEAH, CRANKY.
>> Greg: HE'S SUPPOSED TO
BE THIS KIN OF OLDER, CONGENIAL
MAN.
WHEN HE SAYS SOMETHING LIKE
THAT, IT WORKED FOR TRUMP, IT
WORKED FOR BUSH, EVEN THOUGH IT
WAS INADVERTENT FOR BUSH, IT'S
DEFINITELY ADVERTENT FOR TRUMP,
WHATEVER THAT IS.
>> WHAT'S THE OPPOSITE OF
INADVERTENT, ADVERTENT?
>> IT WORKED FOR TRUMP.
>> I LOVE THAT WORD, ADVERTENT.
THAT'S A GREAT ONE.
I'M GOING TO START TO THROW THAT
AROUND IN MY MEETINGS.
TYS, THE ONLY TIME I GOT
CAUGHT ON A HOT MIC IS WHEN I
HOSTED THE CHIP-IN-DALES.
>> WELCOME BACK.
>> YOU CREEPED ME OUT LAST NIG
AND THEN HE JUST KEEPS RAISING
THE BAR!
I GOT ANGRY, OLD WOMEN SENDING
ME MEAN MESSAGES.
YOU WISH YOU HAD IT SO GOOD.
THANK YOU, GREG.
UM, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M KIND OF SUPER IMPRESSED WITH
OUR VERY OWN DOOCY BECAUSE HE
CLEARLY DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
MONEY.
HE ACTUALLYARES ABOUT BEING A
JOURNALIST, BECAUSE, YES, ACOSTA
WOULD HAVE HAD THE NECK THING
ON, BUT YOU'RE FORGETTING THE
SIX BOOKS THAT ARE GOING TO COME
OUT ABOUT THAT EXPERIENCE.
>> Greg: RIGHT.
>> LITERALLY, HE GOT HIS OWN TV
SHOW BASED ON PRESIDENT TRUMP
HURT MY FEELINGS, AND HIS BOOK
WAS LITERALLY JUST EVERY WORD HE
SAID, AND THEN YOU WOULD SEE HIM
AT -- HE WOULDN'T EVEN DO
INTERVIEWS ANYMORE.
HE'S LIK I'M STANDING OUTSIDE
OF THE RALLYND THESE FOUR
PEOPLE CALLED ME NAMES, AND HE
WAS THE STORY.
AND I COMMEND DOOCY FOR NOT
BECOMING THE STORY WHEN EVERYONE
IS SAYING, HEY, HOW'D THAT FEEL?
HE'S LIKE, HEY, I DIDN'T HEAR
.
I JUST MOVED THROUGH IT HE
CALLED ME AND HE SAID, "SORRY!
NOTHING PERSONAL" AND HE LAUGHED
IT OFF WHICH IS BEING -- AND
MAYBE WE COULD TAKE A LESSON
ABOUT IT -- BUT I DOUBT IT -- HE
IS BEING A JOURNALIST.
ALL THE THINGS THAT HAPPENED ON
THAT, I APPLAUD OUR VERY OWN
DOOCY FOR STAYING THE
JOURNALIST.
I COMMEND HIM FOR THAT.
>> Greg: I'LL GO TO OUR
VERY-OWN KAT TIM --
>> I DON'T BELONG TO ANYONE.
>> YOU'RE THE HOMELS.
THE HOMELESS KAT TIMPF.
WHAT DID YOUAKE OF THIS?
IT'S SO SILLY,UT IT'S GREAT --
YOU KNOW WHAT I LIKE ABOUT THIS
TOPIC?
IT'S FUN.
>> IT IS FUN!
YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE WAS FUN.
>> Greg: WHAT?
>> WAS READING ALL THE COLUMNS
TODAY, OR AT LEAST THE TITLES OF
THEM,IKE, YOU KNOW, JOE BIDEN
SHOULDN'T HAVE SAID THAT, BUT
HERE IS ACTUALLY WHY IT'S NOT A
BIG DEAL.
OK, LIKE WHO ARE YOU WRITING
THESE VERSES?
BECAUSE THE COLUMN LIKE THAT,
YOU HAVE TO BERITING IT VERSUS
SOMEONE.
YOU GOT TO BE ASSUMING SOMEONE
SAYING IT IS A HUGE DEAL BUT NO
ONE SAID THAT.
AND THEN WATCHING SELTZER LIKE
NIGHT, HE'S LIKE, I'M
MR. CONSISTENT.
I'M NOT GOING TO BE LIKE THE
OTHER GUYS.
I'LL SAY IT WAS WRONG -- WHEN
TRUMP SAID THAT ABOUT THE OTHER
GUY, HE SAID IT WAS A THREAT TO
OUR FREE PRESS.
HE SAID IT WAS WRONG AND THE
THREAT TO THE FREE PRESS.
THAT'S NOT CONSISTENT.
WE'VE BEEN JOKING AROUND.
BOTH PETE AND WE'RE HIS DAD WORK
HERE -- BOTH PETER AND HIS DAD
WORK HERE AND THEY'RE BOTH LIKE
MNEH.
>> PETER'S MOM TOOK IT VERY
WELL.
SHE'S THE VICTIM IN ALL OF THIS.
>> Greg: BY THE WAY, WHERE
IS THE JOURNALIST INTERVIEWING
HIS MOM?
>> BECAUSE USUALLY WHEN SOMEONE
-- WELL N MY NEIGHBORHD F YOU
CALLED -- WELL, IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD, IF YOU CALLED ME A
SON OF BITCH, IT'S GO TIME.
NO ONE CALLS MY MOMMA NAMES.
>> THEY KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT IF THEY SAY IT.
>> JIMMY KIMMEL CALLED DOOCY
LAST NIGHT ADAMSON OF A B AND
THAT WAS A DIRECT LIFT FROM WHAT
JESSIE WATERS SAYS.
HE JUST STOLE WATERS' JOKE WHICH
IS SO PATHETIC.
>> SUCKS EVERYONE WHO CALLS ME
NAMES, NONE OF THEM ARE FAMOUS.
>> THAT' HAPPEN ONE DAY.
ONE DAY.
[BLEEP].
SEE?
>>ECAUSE YOU'RE SO FAMOUS.
>> I AM FAMOUS.
>> YEAH, JERK.
>> HA-HA.
>> YOU HAVE TO PUT THE WORD
MAJOR LEAGUE IN FRONT OF THAT.
>> Greg: THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S RIGHT.
I'M NOT THAT GOOD AT
NAME-CALLING.
I SHOULD GET BETTER AT IT.
>> YOU'RE MORE OF A STRUCTURED
PARAGRAPH INSULTER?
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
>> YOU'RE ALL DIGITAL.
>> EXACTLY.
IT'S A WHOLE HE TELLS YOU WHY --
>> Greg: OH STOP IT